your phone
probably knows more about you right now
than your mom because it's the first
thing you touch in the morning it's the
last thing you touch at night and if it
were to be able to view everything it
would know who you call
how long you call what apps you use it
really has a very good it has the
potential to have a really good
understanding of who you are and what
you're up to when people think about
their feelings a lot of times people
feel like feelings are really ephemeral
or that it's just a very sort of
personal thing well it turns out that
our feelings actually do have signals
that show up in things like our heart
rate variability or our galvanic skin
response and so there's actually signal
to our feelings and so what's starting
to happen is we're starting to have the
ability to pick up the biological
signals from various mental states
stress is probably the easiest one and
then another thing is that people feel
like human psychology is very ephemeral
- like we all like to think that we're
completely unique and special snowflakes
and while you know each snowflake has
its own story like my my mother is a
different person than your mother I grew
up in a different neighborhood than you
did when you start to take the data from
our digital exhaust it actually is very
very good at predicting what we're
interested in which is also a good proxy
for human psychology and so you know a
good place to ask oneself is like is
this science fiction or is it real would
be just look at the ad tech business so
when you're on Facebook or when you're
online the advertisers or the people who
are supporting the advertisers know
exactly what you stopped on they know
they they track something called Scrolls
scroll speed so they know what catches
your eye even if you don't click on it
and also there's a lot of research
that's going into micro facial
recognition
making that something that advertisers
can use to really see the effectiveness
of their ads we have you know over a
hundred facial expressions only nine of
which we control and so these things are
great at picking up our emotion what we
like what we don't like and if you add
that into a lot of data about what sites
you went to what you checked out it
becomes fairly easy to create a profile
of someone right now a lot of these
things are really just being used for
advertising but you could also use it to
you could turn it and put it in the
hands of a consumer so that they can
understand themselves better because we
aren't actually really good
often at managing ourselves or knowing
what we're knowing always knowing what
we're up to over time it's one of the
reasons why behavior change is such a
hard task like it's actually hard to
change your behavior to take that and
use that to harness that for you so you
could say this is what I'd like to do
this is what I'd like to change these
are the things that I'd like to improve
on this is what I'd like to understand
about myself and to have all of that
technology instead of having a use case
just to sell things to you for to be a
use case for you to transform into who
you want to be
[Music]